150 archers en passe un test olympique
ce samedi 12 mai pour la troisième fois
la compagnie de tir à l'arc de montigny
le bretonneux organisait une compétition
individuelle sélective pour les
championnats de france avec au programme
la mythique barre des 70 mètres distance
inscrite aux jo dans la mesure en fait
on voit rajouter va m
et bien c'est déjà plus difficile pour
l'arche est donc de bien tenir son arc
et donc d'avoir le même niveau de
précision
on fait toujours les mêmes erreurs on
essaye d'en faire un petit peu moins
quand même mais ça pardonne beaucoup
plus donc toutes les erreurs qu'on peut
faire sur des distances plus rapprochés
sont en résulte a amplifié en cible donc
un oeuf plus rapprochée peut être ainsi
son 1 5 à 77 en plus à distance
olympique les archers ont dû affronter
le vent et la pluie pendant une grande
partie de l'après midi
on doit tirer partout tant il ya juste
la grêle ou les orages qui nous nous
arrête sinon que sony fasse 45 degrés ou
qui pleuvent à foison on tire on est là
la pluie fait descendre les flèches en
tombant dessus en vises un petit peu
plus haut et on croise les doigts pour
que ça suffise
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition en espérant que la
météo soit plus clémente cette fois ci